[Music]
what am I doing with my life every
season I seem to think to myself man
there is just way too much anime coming
out right now and every new season anime
is like hey guys did you say you wanted
even more the fall anime season really
dropped over 60 new shows to choose from
23 new sequels 14 EO Fantasy A bajillion
edgy shows two racing anime toui just
like me for real anime romance SCE of
Life action with so many shows there's
only one thing I know I must do there
too many of them what are we going to
[Music]
do rock and roll freeze hands up daddy
chill what the hell is this is it a bomb
I'm a grenade nobody else can do this
but ninja look what's on the corner of
the desk ninja wanted to see them for
real you want to die I don't want to die
thank God and your mom you didn't see
them from the insane mangao of I'm Hero
Comes an anime about Ninja did you know
ninja still exist of course you don't
that's why they're ninja and like ninja
this anime never lets you know its next
move take this guy just a normal
Foreigner right what's he
doing that's right he's come to Japan to
become ninja now I know what you're
thinking average weeb in Naruto airport
but he's serious he finds a random sign
on the street that says if you piss here
I'll cut your R off clearly this was
left by Ninja a trial this must mean if
you cut off three dicks you become ninja
that's the only possibility he
approaches a random dude urinating in
the streets with a pair of scissors easy
target uh-oh the dick he thought he was
cutting was actually Odin it was a bait
he's outed himself as ninja JK [__]
he's ninja too with ninja moves you can
do ninja things who is this guy he's
first class ninja the show is like a
fever dream set in a yakaza side mission
this is the LW accurate ninjas we need
yeah right they don't have shurikens or
orange jumpsuits or summoning Ninjutsu
but can your favorite ninjas do
this I feel like in 2023 some of the
biggest and best shows have ended up
being sequels to already existing anime
and this season doesn't seem like it's
an exception our favorite anime family
is here again for round two Dr Stone is
apparently going through one of his
better rocks right now Goblin Slayer is
back with some
Goblin slang turkey Avengers is
continuing along with Magus bride seven
deadly sins as a sequel now what and
it's not called Eight lethal wrongdoings
you know I've clowned on seven deadly
sins fans enough now so I'm just not
going to do it I'll let them have this
I'm not going to say anything so uh
let's talk about something else um look
I've just finished playing Final Fantasy
16 recently all right Clive mid when did
you get back all right here's something
I'll gladly clown on Shield hero was a
dumb but fun little isai that did
everything it needed to do in the the
first season so I wondered where the
story could go after that so season 2
clearly heard me and went all right bet
and was horrendously disappointing look
I might be the eai guy but even I've got
to be picky with what I choose to keep
up with I'm a busy man mid so season 3
is going to have to do something really
special to get me interested again doing
a tournament
Arc Eminence and Shadow season 2 now
we're talking which makes this
convenient cuz they are actually the
sponsor of today's video in
collaboration with highve yes I'm not
joking which makes this the easiest
sponsored segment I've ever had cuz I
get to say what I had written down about
the show anyway and pass it off as an ad
in case you missed my previous video
Eminence and Shadow is some of the most
fun I've ever had in the esai genre on
paper a show like this should absolutely
not work it's edgy it's cliche it's
everything you think you roll your eyes
at but it fully Embraces everything and
does not give one care in the world what
you think it serves you cheesy one liner
after cheesy oneliner every dumb power
fantasy you've ever had on a silver
platter and you gobble it up like you're
a 14year old old kid who's just
discovered anime this is what happens
when a show is so Unapologetic about
itself it Knuckles down on being so edgy
it loops around and becomes cool again
if you have a single isekai loving bone
in your body this is what you should be
watching so weebs here's the deal right
now you can watch both seasons of emence
and Shadow legally on high dive where
they are releasing the dub at exactly
the same time as the sub so you can sign
up for a free trial for High Dive by
clicking that link in the description
where you can watch Eminence in Shadow
and show my boy Sid some support along
with a plethora of other anime available
there like osino and Maiden Abyss thank
you very much to Eminence in Shadow
season 2 and hii for sponsoring me today
ad segment over all right guys we got to
get serious for a bit because we have a
new Esports anime about a recovering
gamer a gamer who's Gone without gaming
ever since his dad went for cigarettes
and never came home cuz he's dead at
least that's what his mom told him how
does he still count as a gamer not once
in all his years without gaming did he
ever give up his gamer spirit
exactly a true gamer who hasn't seen
real grass in over four years who has to
take care of a sickly little sister
who's been diagnosed with ligma since
the age of
[Music]
two but despite all these setbacks he
did what most oppressed Gamers couldn't
do when his teammates needed a real
gamer in the face of opportunity he
stood up and took it showing us that
even the most broken of Gamers could
become again that any gamer could
achieve their dreams so in the face of
adversity with the support of his
friends with the crowd cheering him on
he sat down turned on his PC and
uninstalled genin impact okay time for a
real gaming anime remember that feeling
when you saw that first episode of SEO
before you knew the show it would turn
into and the market wasn't saturated
with the same ises VR Gaming anime well
Shang Frontier somehow gave me that same
excitement without even having any
life-threatening Stakes but just
presenting a game that seems genuinely
fun to play we have a gamer who
specializes in completing the most
poorly designed broken ass games only to
completely dominate at a Godlike game my
boy really discovered Elden ring after
playing gollem the video game and you
know he's a real ass sweaty gamer cuz
he's one of those [__] who
plays with a completely naked build
while being a dirty crit stacker this is
the show to watch if you actually want a
gaming anime cuz it seems like it was
made by people who are truly passionate
about video get wait did he just skip a
cut scene oh
no
yes wait is this a guy reincarnated as a
pig who's been taken in by an anime girl
no I can't I can't do this again no the
dogs W enough for you you've come for
our pigs now anime What's Next Cats
Ducks Bears crispy bacon didn't die for
this what did we ever do to deserve this
oh God why do we live in a world where
dogs and pig get more [__] than we
do please tell me there's something this
season that can cleanse my
[Music]
soul there's normally at least one new
show in a season that is an instant must
watch after one episode and I'm glad to
say that this time it's freen beyond
Journey's End freen is not your typical
anime fantasy story there's no Demon
Lord no Grand world saving Adventure no
Earth shattering Stakes are on the line
yet it carries an emotional weight few
shows are ever able to achieve in
episode 1 this is the story of an elf
girl burdened with an abundance of time
a being who in our eyes is functionally
Immortal in the blink of an eye decades
are gone companions age friends die and
all she's left with is the regret for
the wasted time she could have spent
with them it's a story about
appreciating the little things in life
you might have missed and I cannot begin
to tell you how much they are nailing
this adaptation the scenery is drop-
dead gorgeous the Serene atmosphere l
you win and Evan calls Lord of the Ring
a soundtrack Wells up these emotions you
might have forgotten you had for an
experience that warms the soul but what
I love the most is feeling what the
passage of time is like for a being like
freen seasons change in an instance
months can pass scene to scene without
you even knowing she buys some item at a
shop goes in a casual stroll gets lost a
few seconds go by she comes back the
shopkeeper is an old man now there are
so many little things you can miss if
you're not paying attention but if
you're willing to sit down turn off that
Tik Tok brain for a second and give
yourself some time to really get
absorbed in a slow paced show I
guarantee this is going to be one of the
most beautiful Tales you see all
year but that isn't the only thing with
potential this season Undead unluck
already has some of the most inventive
use of anime Powers I've seen we got a
guy with Wolverine esque regenerative
Powers turning his entire body into a
weapon firing off his own body parts
using his Regen to gain momentum midair
it might not be the most complicated
Powers but you can get a sense the
author has put a lot of thought into how
the simplest abilities would actually
affect a person's fighting style if they
refined all their mechanics to the
absolute Peak and I love that feeling
Shan and jump have been on fire recently
with pretty much all of their anime
releases this might not cause as big of
a splash as some of their other hits but
it's definitely one of the dark horses
this season along with this one aside
from knowing it was going to be one of
the most gorgeous looking anime in four
and manga readers were very very excited
I didn't know what to expect out of
Apothecary Diaries so I'm glad to say
that after the premiere I realized oh
this is just House MD in Imperial China
we got Gremlin WWI cooking up different
drugs for the Royal Palace mixed in with
a bit of Poli Intrigue this one
definitely peques my interest I'm just
waiting for that hook to get me fully
invested I'mma Be real though my stupid
ass didn't even know what an apothecary
was before watching this show I know
that's a me thing but how about a name
that even my dumbass can understand if
we want a brand safe name we can just
call it the pharmacist journals but
personally there's one I think that's
more thematically accurate Memoirs of a
crack dealer lid
on into the oven
170 two 2 and 1/ half hours and forget
about it
[Music]
there's a new firefighter anime saving a
Tokyo that's been engulfed By Flames
after someone called jit and mid it's
good to see a firefighter anime where
they actually fight fire like actual
firefighters as opposed to the usual
anime [__] where they fight Firs by you
know just being the [__] out of it okay
what's next ball ball buster by
Studio you sick bastards this is
probably the most grounded Mecca anime
I've ever seen you have a small company
scraping by operate their mix that look
like they should be doing work in a
construction site tasked with
Exterminating giant beasts in a world
where Kaiju have cost the world hundreds
of lives so what's the biggest threat
facing all of humanity
paperwork and right there some Japanese
bureaucrat just busted a studio nut Ron
kashi's forbidden deductions a detective
who detectives so hard he's been banned
from detectiving ever again because ooh
he's so quirky he's not like other
detectives why every time he solves a
case he tells the culprit to kill
themselves yeah this is just Sherlock me
slow to God now time for is this
a or is it just fantasy we got a redo of
redo of heiler where every character
isn't clinically insane there's an
naturual villainous anime about
definitely not Marie Anette going back
in time to stop the French Revolution
with the power of Mo and checking a
privilege now berserk of glasney here's
something unlike anything we've seen all
year all right get this you have a
fantasy protagonist but he's cool
because he wears a dark cloak with black
hair except initially he's super weak
and bullied by some pink-haired [__]
but luckily luckily there's a
prestigious Knight with blonde hair that
protects him for some reason and her
name is Roxy but but the real unique
part is that he has a special skill that
makes him overpowered even at level one
called gluttony that allows him to
absorb the stats of anyone he defeats
and get this he even befriends a talking
sword and oh my God he starts killing
goblins so I don't think there's another
anime like this out there right now ragn
Crimson was an anime that manga readers
were gassing up and with a 40-minute
Premiere I was hoping for more than just
angry man who hates dragons vows to kill
dragons and is also literally too angry
to die maybe this one could fill up the
space for turn your brain off edgy show
of the season but there is a lot and I
mean a lot of edge going around this
season so you better be doing something
special to be standing
out finally it's here
the crumbling guys I got to ask you
something important because I'm just not
sure about this okay listen up so we got
a king announcing he's about to commit
genocide he kidnaps a woman strips her
naked in front of a cheering crowd then
proceeds to execute her In Cold Blood
and parade her severed head around while
the orphan kitchi was taken care of
Screams now I just want to confirm is he
the bad guy if you're looking for Peak
Edge this season well you found it this
shows the subtlety of a white van that
says free candy driven by Jimmy savil
you know what I'm just a sucker for
worlds where magic and Technology
Collide cuz when you have giant Golems
murking tanks getting firebombs by f-35s
while The Angriest Man on Earth shoots a
comically large bullet into a skyscraper
before summoning magic miniguns out of
his ass then I kind of don't give a damn
if this is edgy then sign me the [__] up
because I'm 33 and this is
deep
I don't even know how to describe this
one coming from the late manga of
Sakamoto Desa a pair of twins trick a
wealthy family to adopting them not
knowing that there are actually two of
them and they use that to just
completely [__] with their lives I can't
tell if this is meant to be hilarious or
terrifying this is like some dystopian
YouTuber prank where every prank is
written like that potato chip scene in
Death Note but hey I'm not going to be
calling them out since it seems like
calling out YouTubers in 2023 is
like
that's my [__] location we've got a
new racing anime about formula 4 a thing
I've just learned about thanks to anime
and I feel bad because Initial D is also
back with a squl reboot and look
overtake is coming from the director of
fade zero recreators it looks like it's
got some genuine heart put into it they
even made the effort to make sure all
the sponsors are 100% accurate to what
you'd see in a race but this is EUR beat
ooh an anime about visual novels this
was all right actually think shirro Bako
mixed with new game set in the '90s when
an illustrator gets sent back in time to
the Golden Era of visual novels where
every anime go had those [__] bug
eyes this one was interesting even if
you just want to see how much otaku
culture is evolved from humble
beginnings where akih haror is Electric
Town actually had Electronics in it to
whatever the hell is being made
now oh hey girlfriend girlfriend has
another season and they're adding two
new girlfriends for him to share what's
next five girlfriends six girlfriends
surely even in anime a Haram can only
get so
big
right Mother of God they did it the
final boss of Haram anime has arrived
while we're struggling to even get a
single girlfriend my boy is going for 1
2 5 10 100 girlfriends is the goal and
the journey has just begun this is the
one piece of Riz the Lord of the Rings
of degeneracy this isn't the story of a
giga Chad this is the story of of the
Giga Chad of Giga Chads for a harm
series with a 100 girls endless
possibilities for a fandom to choose
from he managed to convince the anime
Community the anime Community the group
of thirstiest [__] to ever walk
this Earth that there is no best girl
cuz every girl PS in comparison to the
protagonist himself that's right this
man single-handedly ended the Wu Wars
he's too dangerous to be left alive I'm
going to be real after that I don't know
what else romance anime can do to
impress me I mean look at this Our
dating story or right we' got the
popular girl the loser nerd who's never
had a girlfriend never seen that one
before can't wait to watch for two
seasons just to see them hold
[Music]
hand no way we're 45 seconds in is this
what I think it
is virginity the final boss of all
Gamers worldwide losing it has
historically been one of Gaming's
toughest accomplishments requiring the
master of some of the hardest mechanics
you can find in gaming including
downloading dating apps touching grass
and even occasionally talking to women
for decades Gamers have been trying to
break the legendary record set by Runner
Alabama Slammer x69x but today we might
have a new Contender this is one man
story to destroy the losing virginity
any%
[Applause]
speedrun a failed run guys failed run go
next
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too
author Curtis XD basil this functional
degenerate flabber Walky husbando Hub
Mike 808 parasite. exe pain patet Pony
Stark water gist BT and everyone else my
patreon for helping support me for this
month and making this video possible yes
I know I missed talking about just a few
shows but I didn't really have much to
say about them plus this video was
really really long as it is and I kind
of just want to get it out anime if
you're listening to me please I think we
have enough shows now I'm even watching
some shows at like 1.5 and times two
speed and I'm still running out of time
going through every single show that
comes out this season oh God I need to
watch Pluto as well that should come out
and Scott Pilgrim anyway though I hope
you found at least one new show to watch
this season I'd be really worried if
there wasn't at least one but anyway
though that's it from me today I've been
gig hok and I'll see you all next time